tres semanas después de la invasión rusa
ucrania los primeros soldados caídos en
noche aquí son finalmente enterrados en
esta ciudad situada en la costa del mar
negro 24 soldados perdieron la vida en
el primer día de guerra algunos de sus
cuerpos aún no han sido recuperados se
tardó varios días en identificar al hijo
de anatoly basiliensis que murió una
semana después del inicio de la guerra
cuando cuatro cohetes derribaron su
helicóptero
sé bien bajaron en escena y les dijo a
los bajos
luche hoy enterrado a mi amado hijo no
habrá perdón para los caps mientras
sirva en el ejército los destruiré
un avión de bomberos
aunque los bombardeos se han reducido en
8 a 15 en comparación con los primeros
días de la invasión los ataques siguen
produciéndose aquí a diario el trauma de
la ciudad es palpable las calles están
desiertas y decenas de civiles son
evacuados cada día en autobús los que se
quedan rezan por un alto el fuego
aún así esperamos las negociaciones que
están en marcha esto es lo principal que
esperamos porque sin ello creo que la
paz no es posible a corto plazo no es la
primera vez que los soldados de ocho
aquí pagan el precio máximo de la guerra
en el centro de la ciudad se encuentra
un monumento que rinde homenaje a
decenas de soldados de la ciudad
asesinados en el donbass desde que
comenzaron los combates allí en 2014